hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most requested games uh over the past
few days it's a vishwanathan versus
Wesley so from the levit of Cheswick and
it's round three and Wesley did not have
a great start he started by losing two
games now he faces Anand and Anand
started by uh drawing the first two
games so both of them would very much
enjoy a victory here now I'm not gonna
spoil anything but I will say that some
very valuable pieces were sacrificed in
this game so let's check it out uh Anand
has the white pieces and he opens with
E4 we will have a very standard line of
the French defense Ponte 6D for D5 and
Knight the C3 uh the sort of normal or
standard uh line we have Knight to F6
the classical variation and Ponte E5 the
steinits variation we have Knight F to
D7 and now uh Pawn to F4 we have Pawn to
C5 everything is defended and everything
is attacked with Nike F3 and now Knight
the C6 with Bishop the E3 adding more
support to the D4 pawn and Bishop to E7
by Wesley now just a brief moment here a
lot of the players are troubled by Queen
to B6 as it puts so much pressure on D4
and also you've already developed the
dark Square bishop and your B2 Pawn is
hanging this isn't a problem you can
just play Knight to A4 and now the queen
is attacked the C5 Pawn is attacked the
B2 Pawn is defended and if black gives a
check here you can put your knight back
but also C3 is perfectly fine you add
additional support to the D4 pawn and
you don't have to worry about your
knight being attacked with B5 because if
B5 is played then the queen no longer
guards C5 and you can just capture on C5
so it's really not an issue but I've
seen a lot of you have I've been having
issues with this queen to B6 move so
Bishop t7 by Wesley we have Queen to D2
and now Pawn to A6 with d captures on C5
Knight captures and now usually uh
people just go Queen side castles here
sometimes Queen to F2 to put more
pressure on the Knight and C5 but on
just place the nice solid Pawn to A3 uh
we have castles and now Queen into F2
now he puts pressure on the C5 Knight
with Ponte B6 and there is a game that
reads this position where B4 was played
for more world champion Vladimir kramnik
played it against georgmar in the 2016
chess Olympiad and he won that game but
here Anand goes Queen side Castle so we
have a B4 by the former world champion
kramnik and Castles by the former world
champion
B4 is by far the strongest move
recommended by the engine but yeah this
is not a classical game this is a rapid
game I forgot to mention that 10 minutes
per player and you get 5 Seconds
increment starting for move one so of
course Anand wants to mix it up and it
is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game so of course Wesley
does not want his Queen on the same file
as the rookie moves at Queen to C7 and
Bishop to D3 now Anand very much likes
his Bishop here it's on this long
diagonal and okay if Wesley wants he can
eliminate it but that is his choice and
for the moment has the diagonal so a
bishop to B7 Wesley continues
development and now Queen to G3 just
putting more pieces in front of the
black king and now that you don't want
the cf5 on the board so Wesley plays F5
himself and now King the B1 capturing up
a sound doesn't really do all that much
yes you can capture and open up your
Bishop but remember uh Wesley can always
capture the bishop so it's not really an
issue so Anan just goes for a nice
prophylactic King to B1 and now Pawn to
B5 Wesley wants to start the attack with
Pawn to B4 and now Bishop captures on C5
Anan first eliminates the only piece
that can uh make problems for his light
Square bishop and then he plans to move
the queen and open up the position with
G4 to pre to free up this bishop and to
make it a useful attacker Bishop
captures and C5 and queen to H3 now Anan
prepares Pawn to G4 and Wesley of course
doesn't want to allow this uh he wants
the uh somehow counter this he would
very much like to attack with Ponte B4
right away strongest move here is
actually Queen a bishop the C8 just
adding more support to the spawns and
light squares here but he goes spawn to
G6 first which is useful as the queen
now also helps helps out with the
defense of the king side but it allows
Wesley to uh story Island to start his
attack a little bit faster Pawn to G4 we
have Pawn to B for now and Anand starts
by sacrificing the Knight with G
characters and F5 and okay you kind of
have to capture because now you are
fully committed so beat captures on C3
and F captures on G6 and now what can
you do here uh can you capture the pawn
that's the real question if you capture
this then Rook H to G1 and how are you
defending this not a lot of ways you
could play Bishop characters on G1
because why not take the free exchange
or Road captures and now play Rook to E7
to prepare uh sort of a defense here but
after Rook captures and G6 and Rook G7
you don't want to play Queen characters
with check because then the black queen
can just block you you play Rook to H6
first and now if Queen to F7 you can
just deliver a nice Rook to each a
Checkmate so King the f8 will be played
and now you play Queen captures on E6
threatening Rook to AJ threatening Rook
to F6 and there's just really no good
way of defending this if Queen F7 you
just trap the queen if you block with
the Rook then again Rook to F6 will lead
to a Checkmate so nothing can be done
here so the g-pawn cannot be captured
Wesley tries to bring another Defender
into the game but now Rook H the G1 so
first Anand sacrifices a knight now he
sacrifices The Exchange Bishop captures
on G1 Rook captures and G1 and now Rook
on F4 and now what do you think Ananda
played next first he sacrifices the
Knight then he sacrifices The Exchange
and now feel free to pause the video and
figure out what Anan played next while I
give you a couple of seconds
uh so yes for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on uh fully
feeding the tiger and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen captures on E6 and yes we are
going to do this one in slow motion
there we go uh Queen captures an E6 with
check on and sacrifices the queen and
can the queen be captured no because if
the queen is captured then G captures an
H7 opens up a double check by The Rook
End by the pawn and there's no good move
if King tachet is just a matter of Rook
to G8 Checkmate and if you try escaping
then of course Anand will get another
queen into the game and it seems like
okay maybe you're still in the game but
not really if you capture the Knight
it's uh just Rook to G7 Checkmate and if
you don't capture the Knight there is
really not all that much or a knight can
capture on E5 but still Rook to G7 check
King F6 and you don't even have to
capture the queen you could capturing
the queen leads the Checkmate that this
is made in one but it's way cooler if
you don't if you just play Rook to D7
check uh you know it's a it's a matter
of showing class uh to keep as many of
your opponent species on the board as
possible while delivering Checkmate you
know always keep that in mind so after
Queen captures an E6 with check
basically said all right I can't really
capture I have to play King to f8 but
now Anan just played G captures on H7
and he was in this position on move 24
that Wesley Soul resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
all of the threats remain nothing
changes if the queen is captured now
then it's merely a matter of Queen to AJ
to check and after King to E7 just a
nice Rook to G7 check now okay you can
block with Rook to F7 but look at this
Rook captures King captures and now
Knights the G5 check King the E7 and
believe it or not this is now a forced
maintenance 7 uh Queen to H7 checking
the E8 You're Gonna Play Queen to G8
checkerbox the black king in King 37
Queen captures an E6 with checking to
the 8th Queen back to G8 checking to D7
and now it's time to force the king to
E7 Bishop F5 check King has to go to E7
Queen F7 checking to d8 and now of
course Queen to f8 will be Checkmate as
so there we have it a brilliant
brilliant game by a former world
champion
nicely sacrificing the night in the
exchange and then the queen on E6 I mean
what what more can we ask for the you
know still uh at this age just you know
demolishing players not in classical in
Rapid time format and you know not just
any player uh uh um uh I mean Wesley so
who is uh even a world champion himself
in in official random chess uh so you
know that he you know he thrives in
complicated and chaotic positions but
not against the island it would seem uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you very much for
suggesting such a lovely game I would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
Lorena and I would like to thank Kenneth
Fraser Ludy and Ralph and exmeth in
Yasser and sashidara Pita purapu for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest area